Hamburg is a gateway to the world say
it's proud residents it is a major port
and center of trade and commerce and it
often hosts international sporting
events such as cycling competitions
marathons and triathlons and now Hamburg
wants to host the Summer Olympics in
2024 the recently re-elected mayor Olaf
Schultz is full of confidence prepared
everything very well I can feel that
many here are very enthusiastic
enthusiasm will motivate others to let
us bid for the games Hamburg says one
advantage would be the short distances
between the various venues it would
build an Olympic Stadium near the
harbour and ensure that all the other
sites are within a 10-kilometer radius
and some would be dismantled after the
games Hamburg has a very good chance of
winning because the proposals are very
good and because the city has a lot to
offer Hamburg stands a good chance
because everything will be sustainable
but it's hard going up against Berlin
which is already hosted two games when
Hamburg starts something it doesn't
finish it just look at the Elbe
Philharmonic
we shouldn't bid for the Olympics until
that's completed construction of the
Elbe Philharmonic concert hall is wait
behind schedule it will cost ten times
more than planned critics of the bid
like to point that out they suspect
there could well be cost overruns in
building the Olympic venues but there
are other issues as well in some
inner-city districts all hell has broken
loose the infrastructure is straining up
friends are skyrocketing the Olympic
Games would really raise the pressure
even more Frederick Brown from the
Hamburg Olympic bidding team says they
have designed less bombastic more modest
games than we've seen in recent years
the artist in Hamburg is known for being
reserved the skeptics don't want the
monumental ISM from the past they want
sport to be
forefront and the human side that's what
Hamburg wants to love it is past Suzanne
20,000 people gathered last week in
support of hamburg's bid four times more
than expected the German Olympic
Committee is due to decide next month
whether it chooses to back Berlin or
Hamburg